s est invitée aujourd'hui c'est vous
nelson monfort bonjour je connais bien
venu sur ce plateau vous êtes
journaliste sportif l'une des grandes
voix du sports de france télévisions
voix du patinage voix de l'athlétisme et
surtout va du tennis est celle qui nous
intéresse en tout cas ces jours ci vous
arpentez micro à la main les cours des
internationaux de roland garros depuis
30 ans 1992 ce qui fait de vous
évidemment un observateur privilégié
avant de parler de la petite balle jaune
quelques mots d'un plus gros ballon si
vous le voulez bien ou plutôt
malheureusement d à côté du ballon on
parle beaucoup bien sûr ce matin et dans
la presse internationale on en parlait
encore tout à l'heure le raté de la
finale de la ligue des champions au
samedi soir au stade de france en tout
cas côté organisation une soirée
chaotique qui interroge qui interroge
imagine le journaliste sportif que vous
êtes à deux ans des jo de paris c'est
surtout ça le problème parce qu est ce
que la france est capable ou non
d'organiser un événement de grande
envergure ça c'était déjà un événement
de très grande envergure les jo c'est x
peut pas ressent peut-être et et en plus
le stade de france comme vous le savez
sera le coeur l'épicentre de ces de ces
jeux olympiques alors franchement que
ces images tournent effectivement le
monde entier c'est une catastrophe pour
l'image internationale de la france cet
événement a quand même été suivie en
direct par près de 500 millions de
téléspectateurs en football c'est
vraiment après peut-être une finale de
coupe du monde c'est l'événement le plus
suivi n'ont cessé vertement
catastrophistes qui s'est passé et puis
maintenant on commence à avoir des
responsabilités et qui avait cassé la
question comment aquila exactement en
tout cas sûrement pas aux supporters
espagnols ni aux supporters anglais les
supporters anglais ça je tiens à dire
parce qu on a dit beaucoup de choses sur
l'angleterre à l'époque des hooligans
c'était il ya plus de vingt ans on était
vraiment exemplaire dans cette affaire
se sont fait tabasser se sont fait voler
se sont fait enfin vraiment jeu
imaginé quand même quelqu'un à qui mais
et non elles sont voit sur ces images
sont pas tous des milliardaires jirs qui
met vraiment beaucoup beaucoup
d'économies pour payer des billets à
plus de 1000 2000 euros parfois venir
passer un week end à paris et se faire
tabasser voler comme au coin du bois
enfin c'est cette affreuse qui s'est
passé ça ça dépasse très largement le
cadre du sport c'est vraiment affreux ça
remet pas en cause la capacité
de la france d'organiser de grands
événements sportifs non parce que par le
tournoi de tennis de roland garros était
exactement l'exemple contraire ou là ça
se passe vraiment hyper bien avec un
public magnifique il n'y a aucun aucun
débordement maintenant chez les knights
chercheuse donc le public est invité à
inviter le mot à quitter les lieux pour
qu'un autre public arrive à 20h45 tout
ça se passe en parfaite harmonie alors
dans le public du stade de france
justement samedi soir il y avait un
supporters durel pas tout à fait comme
les autres qui s'appelle rafael nadal il
a d'ailleurs raconté à nos confères de
la fp qu'il avait rejoint le stade de
france en marchant sur l'autoroute tant
le bazar était totale bref un nadal qui
a encore livré pour parler tennis nelson
monfort hier après midi un match
absolument exceptionnel en en huitièmes
de finale alors l'expression au finale
avant la lettre c'est peut-être le quart
de finale qui va avoir lieu contre novak
djokovic demain donc c'est pas encore
shekels diffuseur mais cette ce match là
était en tout cas un apéritif de premier
choix qui a lancé la première fois je
crois à la connaissance que le coach de
l'un et le neveu et et londres pardon de
l'autre
toni nadal déchiré toni nadal l'oncle
l'oncle de de rafah en larmes à la fin à
la fin du match tout était réuni pour
faire de ce match à un moment de loin
plus loin pour l'instant le plus beau
match du tournoi et qui sait peut-être
restera-t-il comme le plus beau match du
avec un jeune canadien qui n'a pas
démérité un félix roger alias him on
entendra parler de lui je pense oui
effectivement demain sans doute l'un des
matches les plus attendus de cette
session à 2022 nadal-djokovic un
classique dont j'espère qu'il sera
diffusée chez nous voilà si vous le
dites parce que je précise il ya un
enjeu sur l'heure à laquelle aura lieu
cette rencontre si la rencontre a lieu
le soir ce ne sera pas diffusée sur
france télévisions ce serait dommageable
bas ce serait dommageable pour oui ce
serait même extrêmement dommageable
parce que évidemment nous nous
réunissions un public beaucoup beaucoup
plus nombreux et de priver les
passionnés de tennis dont le grand
nombre d'adrs une affiche comme cela
sera extrêmement extrêmement dommageable
mais ça ça vous ça nous dépasse vous et
moi hélas oui ça se décide d'en sous 2
sans doute en coulisses alors rafael
nadal joue un 14e sacre à à roland
garros comme l'euro qu'est ce qui fait
de lui un champion
complet c'est un c'est un champion
extraction elle s'est assise d'un
champion exceptionnel sur le court mais
également dans la vie au fond qu'est-ce
qui reste à la fin ce sont des qualités
humaines qui sont saluées par tous à
commencer par les ramasseurs de balles
chez chaque année nous faisons à 202
petit sondage afin pour savoir qui est
le jour le plus agréable et les ramasser
handball sont évidemment très aux
premières loges de sang en première
ligne vous savez une manière de manière
de tendre la serviette et non pas de la
jeter une manière de demander les balais
quasiment me dire merci non donc non
seulement si on considère le nombre de
tournois du grand chelem il est à 21
dont qui ont vidé de peu considéré comme
le plus grand joueur de va dire de l'ère
moderne même si djokovic aura peut-être
son mot à dire mais en plus haut point
de vue des qualités humaines c'est un
garçon que je que je vaux lord d'assez
bien connaître lui et son clan parce
qu'il est très clan c'est un garçon
vraiment pour le cas j'ai énormément
d'estimé
qu'est-ce qu'on n'a pas dit encore de
lui qu est ce qu on ne sait pas que vous
pourriez nous dire qu'il est capable de
gagner une 14e fois roland garros vous
vous souvenez de son premier de ces
premiers roland garros était en 2005 son
premier la mouline sallenave en
absolument il avait il y avait 18 ans et
célèbre dans l'année je crois que ces
jours ci la semaine prochaine dans cette
semaine je le 3 le 3 ou le 4 juin à
quelque chose comme ça chaque année à
roland garros 6 offre le plus beau des
cadeaux que cas quasiment chaque année à
savoir une victoire dans ce tournoi qui
est bien possible qu'elle arrive de
nouveau de nouveau cette année je crois
je crois je crois qu'on a on a vraiment
tout dit sur ce sur ce garçon son
altruisme sa générosité ses qualités
humaines comme j'essayais qu'il ya
quelques instants à la fin de sa caisse
qui restera c'est ça
côté femmes nelson monfort le tennis
mondial manque de figures marquantes
comme on a pu le connaître il ya
quelques années avec les soeurs williams
sur qui est ce que vous me voyez le
tennis féminin un grand problème un vrai
problème
d'identité et pauline c'est à dire que
comme vous le dit très justement les
soeurs williams devront montrer un petit
peu plus en arrière monica seles steffi
graf martina hingis tout ça ce sont des
noms dans tout le monde se souvient
aujourd'hui je mets au défi les
spectateurs et même les connaisseurs de
tennis de dire comme ça spontanément qui
sont les numéros les tops 5 joueuses
m'ont même moi je n'y arrive pas chez in
gaspille attaque pologne et la numéro un
mondiale aujourd'hui si j'étais à la
place de la wta donc là tennis
association des filles je me comment je
me poserai vraiment des questions sur le
sur le manque d'identité de ses joueuses
alors c'est assez injuste parce qu'elles
pratiquent un tennis magnifique hat est
bien supérieur c'est l'évolution à celui
que pratique et mettons steffi graf mais
il ya un vrai problème d'identité et il
n'y a plus de stars c'est la raison pour
laquelle d'ailleurs une sérénade 2e
degré moines venus mais serena williams
est encore plus loin dans en carrière
parce que c est les 12es les plus
connues elles sont franchement je ne
sais pas trop réfléchir en disant cela
je pense que serena williams est plus
connue elle seule que l'ensemble des
joueuses réunis et ça ça pose un vrai
problème
à écouter côté français on a vu les des
beaux matches là deviennent paris oui
bravo bravo elle a passé elle a passé
deux dynamiques 19 ans voisine elle
habite à boulogne 500 mètres du stade en
plus une jeune fille très jeune fille
très équilibré très très mature je
trouve pour son pur sang arabe ce qui
est le cas souvent chez les joueurs de
tennis professionnels qui ont beaucoup
de maturité un très jeune âge félix à
nantes on parlait en également
incarnation inquiets canadiens sauf que
nelson monfort le tennis français n'a
pas eu cette année non plus un grand
sourire comme c'est le cas depuis
plusieurs années ça fait plusieurs
années qu'ils français ne passe pas n'y
arrive pas dans ce tournoi mais pas
qu'eux à roland garros d'ailleurs quel
est le problème avec le tennis français
le problème c'est qu'une génération
qu'on a appelé les mousquetaires
peut-être un peu hâtivement parce que
ces mousquetaires là sont quand même
donc quand même pas le palmarès de jean
borotra rené lacoste et j'en passe à
avant guerre c'est que ces mousquetaires
là arrive à la fin de leur carrière et
que leur leur génération n'est pas
na pas été remplacé mais quoi ils sont
allés malformés la génération d'un prêt
à écouter ça c'est une question qu'il
faut peut-être poser le problème c'est
que aujourd'hui il ya des accueils à nab
une ou deux des académies privé qui
fonctionne plutôt bien je pense
notamment à celle de patrick mouratoglou
qui aidèrent notre consultant sur ce sur
ce tournoi qui a une académie dans le
dans le média sophia antipolis non non
non et non à de cannes mais les
structures privées font une sorte de
concurrence aux structures publiques
fédérales sedira et cette concurrence ne
semble pas être extrêmement saine c'est
c'est plutôt comme ça que comme ça si
vous voulez donc j'espère me tromper
mais diane paris peut-être bien de paris
pourrait être d'autant comme je viens de
lire et quelques minutes le tennis
féminin se cherche un peu diane paris
d'ici deux ou trois ans pourrait
j'espère être dans le top 10 mondial
voilà on salue bien sûr jo wilfried
tsonga est arrêté dans la douleur le
pauvre ce tournoi de roland garros non
seulement le tournoi mais aussi sa
carrière de joueur pro ça fait 30 ans je
le disais tout à l'heure nelson que vous
êtes en bord de terrain à roland garros
avec ce style inimitable qui est le
vôtre qui consiste notamment en traduire
à traduire en direct et à la fois vos
questions et les réponses de
l'interviewé aucune forme de laisse
traduire les émotions plus et c'est pas
une traduction littérale si vous voulez
c'est une sinon on fera je pense appel à
un traducteur de l'onusida qui ferait ça
sans doute beaucoup mieux que moi et moi
ce que j'ai c'est d'être cédée train un
passeur d'émotions
et voilà qu'elle soit positive quand ce
sont des vainqueurs comme rafa hier soir
ou quand elles soient évidemment
négative ce qui est évidemment rêvé
vaincu aucune lassitude ou au bout d'un
moment je dirais bon ça fait trente ans
que je voulais c'est ce que je dirai ce
que je vous en donne l'impression non
pas du tout mais non je rigole asie au
bout d'un moment je ressens non mais je
ressens cette extraordinaire privilège
que d'avoir accompagné toutefois
plusieurs générations de champions en
parler de langage accompagné
pratiquement toute sa carrière
rafa vous m'autorisez à l'appeler comme
ça puisque vrai qu'on a établi des des
rapports ont montré très privilégié j'ai
accompagné ces treize victoires à
roland-garros série en cours comment
comment être là c'est au contraire je
ressens ça comme un comme un grand grand
privilège
tennis 2024 bien sûr le tennis
olympiques seront là en roland garros en
un mot vous vous y serez ah bah je
rentre en tout cas je me suis donné ça
comme un petit peu comme comme comme
jolie échéance ces jeux de de paris 2024
qui j'espère connaître au moins de chaos
que c'est la soirée d'avant-hier au
stade de france oui on l'espère en
attendant on peut lire on peut relire
vos mémoires olympiques qui sont sortis
chez michel lafon il ya quelques temps
en attendant les prochains jeux merci
encore nelson monfort d'être venu ce
matin